Wendy how are you oh my god you look you
look you look how is LA treating you I
gonna ask I love LA you love you love oh
I have New York more I'm going home
tomorrow life here suddenly has been
really good I've been here for five days
I'm gonna get my chicken and waffles I'm
going back to my hotel oh my gosh I
can't believe you're in my face let me
ask real quick listen your your time
here the Kardashians all right you guys
are rekindle you guys are weekend oh my
god but I love them all right I always
did like you know I just know the media
take it out of context though the media
taken out of context sometime times the
way that the you know the way that you
said things and the media always takes
things out of context but you'll kick
some part of the media here's the deal
though we're on hiatus now like wine get
back to New York tomorrow so that for
moments of vacation which is ridiculous
nice I don't know what I'm doing with
myself I missed my Wendy Watchers but we
have live shows on July 8th and I will
be sure to clarify in my Wendy voice
what me and the Kardashians and
Hollywood and China and and that's what
I'm saying the blac chyna Kim and Kris
you guys are all good you guys are all
good yeah look look how is it spending
time with them
enlightening alright pepper-spray you
don't want the pepper stuff you know
you know what the very people mom ok
Wendy Wendy Wendy when you want one more
thing here Kevin if you know if you
don't mind me asking here that's on
Kevin my friend always a friend
please don't ask about Kevin I won't
have an ain't seen you outside yeah and
I'm sensitive to that but that is not
Kevin in that some what's your name sure
know what don't do it I won't ask you
say ok look how are you in the film you
doing you in you and young Kevin right
young keV and I are fine you know big
Godspeed and
happens in life happens and it's okay
I've still got a very full life really
oh my god I have plan on this but it is
what it is I have got to go eat my food
with potato salad
everything and I've got a good on the
plane in the morning but I have a very
full life thank you for watching I would
ask you to respect our privacy but
please I don't respect people's privacy
that's why I'm the hot topic so turning
bat is a fair game but all three of us
are doing fine are we are we gonna see
the three of you guys yeah I mean
together that evening it may be not as a
married yeah well Kevin's got a graduate
from college is going into the sophomore
year he's gonna get married or whatever
he's gonna celebrate yes
everybody's got a grouchy gonna be back
with his father again not a part I mean
you know stuff happens in life yeah look
I'm hungry and I'm hungry and I got it I
got a guy understand when you listen
you're your greatest and welcome welcome
welcome to LA and you all right when any
of you
I'm Ricky Williams but not just because
I would soar to what is that all right
what are we gonna put on to go to the
airport honey this is some leggings I
didn't cropped little top thing you know
how I do did we
okay now I'm not
understand that I decide I just I just I
just want to talk about the older Kevin
and the young and forget it
you know what you're really respectful
it's not fair especially him over there
to his friends yeah yeah come on Wendy
Wendy
[Music]